foreign
okay and Welcome to our
Lincoln live audience our YouTube live
audience
and of course everyone here on Zoom hope
that you are liking the new platform
that we're on
in this new year
and
I want to welcome you to
accelerating your career with the coding
boot camp from Caltech Center for
technology and management education
we'll be hearing from
Mike Ash a little bit later
um
and we'll also hear from Mark vendra who
is one of our senior instructors
um Mike is the director of Market
development for Caltech ctme and
he's one of the people in charge of this
program so
we'll let you hear from him in a little
bit
our agenda today we're going to be
asking a few questions about you during
this presentation
um My Name by the way is Stuart Creek
should probably
let you know that here
and
I will simply learn we're the delivery
partner for Caltech for this program
we're going to talk a bit about full
stack coding careers we'll talk about
Caltech boot camp and How It prepares
you for one of those careers and we'll
talk about learner outcomes and take
your questions so put those in the Q a
box
we'll be able to keep track of them
there it's much easier than in the chat
so about careers in full stack coding
this is where we're going to um
hear from Mike
allow me to do that
thanks Kurt
um so let's talk a bit about full set
coding or uh sometimes we'll see it as
FSD full stack development full stack
web development
uh we might use those terms
interchangeably
um so everything all applications today
whether you're building something
discrete or Enterprise applications it's
it's all web-based right
um and what we're doing is is really try
to
advance the capabilities of of people
and companies to create uh web-enabled
systems that are are rock solid and high
quality and what we'll do in in a
program like this is talk about how how
does all that work from from the front
end the presentation layer the back end
the different databases and one of the
things that need to be in place uh to
take some of that complexity out for you
the the new coder
um we're going to be talking about the
different types of of tools uh the
different kinds of trade-offs like we
went to take this platform over this
platform
and we'll get into that um and all the
things that you really need that you're
going to get a great exposure there are
a number of tools there's a lot of stuff
to it
um and I hope you're here
for the ride
the
when we talk about full stack
development that could mean a lot of
things to a lot of people it can also
mean different roles that that you can
take so whether you
want to be somebody who is a jack of all
trades that can really
um
uh perverse whole all the different
parts of
being on the back end the front end
um that's great you can develop your
skills for that if you want to
concentrate on on uh really what's about
the the front end and the presentation
layers uh we'll get into that the rules
of I've just been in into the databases
uh ux UI this is a perfect program for
people who also want to get into design
and really understand and work with
developers around
the whole user experience right
um software engineering and really
understanding software architecture so
we're going to try to prepare people for
these different roles with what you're
going to get into and that this is just
a great kind of jumping off point to
figure out okay what what do I want to
do
in I was I was talking to Stuart uh you
know often when we we do the uh boot
camp info sessions
some of the Technologies you know
continue to change so at least maybe
every year we might add new technologies
on here just to
keep up with what's happening in the
industry
um but we're going to cover uh the core
skills that everybody needs to know uh
the Technologies and the Frameworks
um
and and really what we've also added is
uh the hardness for Enterprise
applications
um the spring framework is a is a great
one
uh to uh to bring into this uh we're
going to talk about how to work with
other systems and apis uh whether that's
using the Java persistent apis
um rest others
and we'll cover a little bit about the
uh different uh
um
methodologies uh so what I mean by that
is agile
um other traditional ones and that what
are the skills that you need to know as
a team member and what project managers
are going to be expecting of you
one specific framework
you know often what we we do the boot
camp info sessions
some of the Technologies you know
continue to change so at least maybe
every year we might add new technologies
on here just to
keep up with what's happening in
Industry
um but we're going to cover uh the core
skills that everybody needs to know uh
the Technologies and the Frameworks
um
and and really what we've also added is
uh the hardness for Enterprise
applications
the spring framework is a is a great one
uh to uh to bring into this uh we're
going to talk about how to work with
other systems and the apis uh whether
that's uh using the Java persistent apis
um rest others and uh we'll cover a
little bit about the uh different uh
methodologies uh so what I mean by that
is agile
other traditional ones and what are the
skills that you need to know as a team
member and what project managers are
going to be expecting of you
go ahead yeah so
all right
so this is one of the polls that I
talked about
we will start that in just a second
if you're watching on a streaming
service please put your answers A B C or
D into your
comment or chat box
and let this poll run for a bit
and
I see the numbers have stopped changing
so I'm going to go ahead and share the
results with you
and today's audience it's people uh you
haven't taken a program of this site
because you haven't found one that's got
a comprehensive curriculum
covers all of those skills and tools
that Mike was talking about and followed
by you don't think that you'd get
practical exposure that would allow you
to show that you're job ready so let's
talk a little bit about those
factors
this program is the Caltech coding boot
camp it's a six month program it's
completely online
and it has a comprehensive curriculum
that we'll talk about in a few moments
um with integrated labs and
projects that are all in the same online
environment the learning management
system
where you take your online virtual
classes so every week you'll be taking
classes with an instructor live
and they'll be covering the material let
me talk about exercises answering your
questions you'll be able to interact
with your classmates during those
periods and then you'll do your
labs and projects
during the rest of the week but it's
available to you 24 7 so you can fit
that into any time that you have
available
we talk about a commitment of 10 to 15
hours a week it doesn't have to be at a
particular set time other than the
of course the set times for the virtual
classes so it's something that you can
accomplish
within your your working life
um unlike a traditional boot camp where
you have to travel somewhere and get
locked in a conference room for weeks at
a time
and
try to
follow along for six or eight hours a
day
this